Transcription: Dominique Partridge
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
« On n’est pas condamné à l’échec.
Voilà le chant
des combattants banlieusards
et fiers de l’être,
j’ai décidé d’écrire
l’hymne des battants,
ceux qui ne font pas toujours
ce que l’on attend d’eux.
Si à ce jour il y a deux France,
qui peut le nier ?
Le système ne m’a rien donné.
J’ai dû le braver.
J’aspire à être un gagnant,
donné perdant,
parce qu’on vient de la banlieue.
Les yeux dans les bleus,
mais des bleus dans les yeux.
Pourquoi eux à l’ENA,
nous dans les ghettos ?
Mais une question reste en suspens :
qu’a-t-on fait pour nous-mêmes ?
On n’est pas condamné à l’échec.
On est condamné à réussir. »
Cher public,
ces quelques lignes déclamées
ne sont pas le fruit
d’une quelconque compétence artistique
de ma part ou littéraire.
Elles sont l’appartenance d’un slameur,
rappeur français célèbre,
du nom de Kery James.
Dans son texte,
que je ne vous ai lu que partiellement,
il décrit, je le crois, avec justesse,
d’une part,
ce que peut receler l’expression même
d’un sentiment d’incompétence,
tel que la psychologie sociale l’a définit
comme étant ce jugement négatif
porté sur soi-même.
Mais d’abord et surtout
ce que peut être la force
de l’intériorisation
d’images dévalorisantes
de sa propre identité ethno-sociale.
Dans le clip vidéo
de cette même œuvre musicale,
on peut y voir des personnes
toutes issues de la « diversité »,
comme on dit,
et qui occupent aujourd’hui
des postes à responsabilité,
même si,
comme le répète le refrain,
elles ont eu mal.
Mais tout de même,
comment expliquer qu’à un âge adulte,
de telles images défavorables
de sa propre identité puissent perdurer
et s’ancrer durablement
dans la construction sociale
des individus ?
La faute à qui ?
À quoi ?
Eh bien, je vous propose d’utiliser
ce que nous sommes en train de vivre.
Là, tout de suite,
maintenant,
tous ensemble.
Car en réalité,
il ne vous aura suffi que de deux minutes.
Deux petites minutes.
Deux minutes que je suis devant vous,
deux minutes que vous m’observez,
deux minutes,
que vous me voyez, 120 secondes.
Et vous m'avez déjà catégorisée.
Vous m'avez rangé dans une case.
Vous vous êtes forgé
une impression globale
sur ce que je suis,
alors que vous ne possédez
que très peu d’éléments
concernant ma personne.
Alors, inutile de se sentir confus
ou même mal à l’aise,
puisque ce mécanisme de catégorisation
est tout à fait naturel et commun.
Et l’explication est simple:
les capacités de traitement
de l’information de notre cerveau
ne nous permettent pas
de traiter l’ensemble des informations
quand on rencontre une personne.
De fait, notre système cognitif,
notre système de pensée,
va fonctionner sur un mode économique.
Bon, si vous préférez,
vous avez activé
tout un ensemble de connaissances
stockées dans votre mémoire,
ces fameux,
pour ne pas dire fichus stéréotypes.
Les stéréotypes, ces idées toutes faites,
affranchies de tout examen critique,
ces ennemis de la pensée logique
peuvent même parfois agir
comme des prophéties
qui finissent par se réaliser.
Effectivement, certains individus,
à force d’être confrontés
à des images négatives
de leur propre identité,
vont penser ces images comme
leur étant personnellement applicables
et vont fortement les intérioriser.
C’est ce que la psychologie sociale
appelle l’auto-stéréotype.
Mais il y a plus grave encore,
lorsqu’un stéréotype négatif
est largement diffusé dans une société,
il peut constituer, pour les individus
stéréotypés une menace,
un poids qui va considérablement réduire
leur capacité à réussir.
Ces élèves ou ces individus ayant peur
de confirmer
le stéréotype négatif en question,
c’est ce qu’on appelle
la menace du stéréotype.
Moi je m’appelle
Nafissa Belbouab Zaaraoui
et professionnellement,
j’ai trois casquettes.
Je suis professeur des écoles.
J'ai une classe.
Je suis également maître formateur.
Je forme les enseignants
à l’Institut national supérieur
du professorat
et je suis doctorante
en sciences de l’éducation.
Mes travaux de recherche portent
sur l’influence des représentations
et biais perceptifs des enseignants
qui œuvrent dans nos quartiers populaires
sur le sentiment d’incompétence
de leurs élèves.
Vous comprenez bien, dès lors,
que transférés au domaine de l’éducation,
ces mécanismes réducteurs de la pensée,
peuvent avoir des effets dévastateurs
chez les élèves lorsqu'ils sont véhiculés
par leurs enseignants.
Effets dévastateurs,
d’autant plus que le tableau
de notre système éducatif
n’est pas franchement reluisant.
On a l’école qui, dans le même temps
est l’une des écoles
les plus inégalitaires au monde
et la moins performante.
Quelques chiffres,
peut-être pour mieux comprendre :
par exemple, 90% des élèves,
des enfants de cadres ou enseignants
réussissent à obtenir leur bac
sans embûches,
sans problèmes
à la fin de leur cursus collège et lycée,
quand ce n’est le cas
que pour 40 % d’enfants d’ouvriers,
à peine un élève sur deux.
Et soyons honnêtes,
ce n’est pas tout à fait le même bac
qu’ils obtiennent, mais passons.
Des chiffres internationaux, maintenant :
les évaluations internationales
qui visent à évaluer
le niveau scolaire des élèves
de quinze ans
dans plusieurs pays du monde,
nous révèlent pourtant
que plus de la moitié des élèves français
obtiennent parmi
les meilleurs résultats au monde.
Parmi les 50% restants,
nous avons 30% d’élèves massivement issus
des quartiers populaires
en grande difficulté scolaire
et qui obtiennent parmi
les moins bons résultats au monde.
Alors, est-ce que ça veut dire
que l’école ne fait rien ?
N’a rien fait ? Non.
Ce serait injuste de penser cela.
C’est plutôt qu’historiquement,
l’école n’a jamais été conçue,
dans son organisation,
pour faire réussir tous les élèves.
Depuis le XIXᵉ siècle,
et ça n’a pas beaucoup changé depuis,
la mission principale
qui lui a été attribuée
est une mission de tri et de sélection,
tri et sélection,
bien sûr, des meilleurs élèves.
Il faut dire en réalité
qu’il y a une partie de la population
qu’on pourrait décrire comme dominante
qui n’a pas trop intérêt
à ce que le système change,
qui craint même que le système
puisse changer.
Craindre un élargissement de la masse
de ceux qui réussissent,
ce qui se ferait au détriment
des élèves les plus performants.
Qu’y a-t-il à craindre ?
Quels risques, quels risques y a-t-il
à porter une attention toute particulière
à faire réussir tous les élèves,
quelle que soit leur origine sociale ?
Qu’y a-t-il à craindre ?
Quels risques y a-t-il à bâtir
une politique d’intérêt général éducative
fondée sur le principe d'égalité ?
Peur du déclassement peut-être,
peur de s’éloigner
du modèle méritocratique qui finalement
ne profite qu’aux plus favorisés ?
Vous savez, le fameux
si « on veut, on peut »,
oui, mais des fois on veut vraiment,
mais on ne peut pas.
Alors moi je ne peux pas me résigner
à avoir cette vision déterministe,
fataliste, essentialiste,
décliniste de notre école.
Et pour vous montrer ce que peut-être
l’un des leviers possibles.
J'aimerais vous raconter une histoire.
Cette histoire, c’est celle de Sarah,
jeune étudiante
fraîchement diplômée du CRPE,
le concours de recrutement
des professeurs des écoles
et qui va faire classe
pour la première fois.
C’est sa toute première affectation,
école Charcot,
au plein milieu des quartiers populaires
de l’agglomération blésoise en REP,
Réseau d'éducation prioritaire.
Ce sont ses toutes premières
journées de classe.
Tous ses élèves sont félicités,
récompensés,
considérés pour leurs efforts,
même minimes.
Sarah a de fortes attentes
vis-à-vis de ses élèves.
Mais ce n'est pas tout.
Elle arrive en classe
avec presque aucun à priori les concernant
car elle les voit tous
comme de potentiels superhéros
du français ou des mathématiques.
Sarah refuse de croire qu'on peut mettre
tout le monde dans le même sac.
Elle refuse de céder à cette tentation
pourtant toute commune, nous l'avons dit,
de catégoriser les autres,
de les ranger dans des cases,
comme elle range
dans le tiroir de son bureau,
les feutres avec les feutres,
les stylos avec les stylos,
les crayons avec les crayons.
Parce qu’à priori,
ils ont les mêmes caractéristiques.
Disons que c'est un peu cela.
Pour Sarah, ces élèves sont des crayons.
Bon, pour la société,
c’est des crayons pas très jolis,
trop petits et cassés,
un peu usés par le regard
que les autres ont porté sur eux.
Mais Sarah, elle pense que ces crayons,
il suffit de les tailler minutieusement
afin qu’ils puissent révéler
toute leur puissance créatrice,
comme dessiner des capes
de super héros capables de révéler
un sentiment de compétence personnelle.
Bon, vous l’aurez compris,
Sarah n’est qu’un personnage fictif,
malheureusement trop peu représentative
de ce que l’on peut voir sur le terrain.
C’est une forme de stéréotype très positif
de ce que devrait,
pourrait, être la parfaite enseignante,
affranchie de ses idées toutes faites.
Oui, mais comment Sarah a-t-elle pu
transcender ces stéréotypes,
les dépasser, les conscientiser ?
Eh bien, Sarah, elle a reçu
une formation professionnelle de qualité,
fondée certes, sur la didactique
des enseignements fondamentaux
tels que le français, les mathématiques,
mais elle s’est ouverte
à d’autres champs disciplinaires,
tels que la psychologie sociale.
Elle a appris par exemple,
les travaux sur les files d’attente,
appelés aussi effet Rosenthal,
plus communément connu
sous le nom d’effet Pygmalion,
terme un peu galvaudé à mon sens,
et dont on a perdu un peu
la profondeur, je trouve.
Rosenthal, donc,
ce psychologue américain des années 70,
qui a mené une expérience
vraiment remarquable.
Il a pris un ensemble d’étudiants
qui était chargé d’étudier
le comportement de rats
dans un labyrinthe.
Il a scindé le groupe en deux.
Le premier groupe a reçu des rats
dits « intelligents »,
alors que le deuxième groupe avait reçu
des rats dit « bêtes ».
Ce sont donc ces dominations
qui ont donné aux rats.
Les étudiants du groupe un ont
fortement sollicité , stimulé, leur rat,
les pensant plus performants,
alors que les étudiants du groupe deux
sont partis défaitistes
quant aux performances de leur art
et les ont beaucoup moins stimulés.
En réalité,
ce que les étudiants ne savaient pas,
c’est qu’aucun rat n’était
plus intelligent ou plus bête
que son congénère.
Et la conclusion de cette expérience
est sans appel.
Effectivement, les rats du groupe un
ont mieux réussi dans le labyrinthe
que les rats du groupe deux.
En réalité,
ce n’était que la perception
que les étudiants avaient
de leur rat qui changeait.
C'était la seule variable.
Pourquoi vous raconter cela ?
Tout cela pour vous dire quoi ?
Que si l’on forme bien nos enseignants
à conscientiser les risques inhérents
à ces mécanismes,
ces processus réducteurs de la pensée,
si l’éducation nationale
fait le pari audacieux
de s’ouvrir
au dialogue interdisciplinaire,
si la recherche en éducation
valorise les travaux interdisciplinaires,
je suis sûre que notre école serait
capable du meilleur et réduire
ainsi considérablement
les inégalités sociales en son sein.
Et c’est ce que j’essaye
de faire modestement à travers
mes travaux de recherche
qui sont à l’intersection
de la psychologie sociale,
des sciences, de l’éducation
et de l’approche socio clinique.
Il y a donc des laboratoires qui osent
et valorisent tant il faut garder espoir.
J'aimerais finir en vous faisant
une petite confidence.
Je vous ai parlé de Sarah tout à l'heure.
En réalité, ce n’est pas
un personnage si fictif que ça.
Sarah a vraiment existé,
mais au masculin,
c’était mon professeur de CM1.
M. Berla, qui affranchi de ces préjugés,
m’a toujours montré qu’il croyait en moi,
que c’était possible, que j’étais capable,
car oui, je n’étais pas une bonne élève.
Je suis sûre que chacun d’entre vous
a le souvenir précieux et vif
d’un enseignant qui a compté
parce qu’un jour il vous a dit
que vous étiez capable.
Alors parce que chaque élève compte,
parce que les quartiers populaires
ne sont pas des territoires perdus
de la République,
parce qu’ils ne sont pas
condamnés à l’échec,
parce que c’est souvent
le tout premier regard
qui est déterminant.
Apprenons tous,
autant que nous sommes,
quel que soit notre domaine professionnel,
quel que soit notre statut social
ou économique,
à être maître de nos stéréotypes
pour ne plus en être esclave.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)